thank you alejandro with a new
tournament comes a new tradition and we
have the executive director of the st
louis chess club tony rich joining us to
present one of our champions with the
championship bracelet tell us a little
bit about that tony and about this
tournament what does it mean for you so
the american cup is a new format as you
guys have heard over the past 10 days
we're super excited to host it uh here
at the chess club it's always been on my
bucket list to have a knockout style
event uh the players obviously came to
fight it was exciting chess every day so
first and foremost i'd like to thank all
of the players for
making it a great event of course i'd be
remiss if i didn't thank dr genie and
rex singfield they really are the
driving force behind chess in the united
states and another event like this is
just more evidence of their commitment
to the game i'd like to thank the event
arbiters upstairs smooth sailing
throughout the whole event our deputy
arbiter brian yang chief arbiter chris
byrd and chris was instrumental in
helping me design the the regulations
for this event as well so
a big thanks to him as well uh right so
uh we always do trophies for these
events we decided to mix it up a little
bit this time around um you know just
like in golf you get the the jacket or
you know you win the super bowl you get
the rings we've decided that for this
event we will have bracelets so tiffany
and company um produce these beautiful
bracelets uh they are sterling silver id
bracelets that will be engraved with the
winner's name
as well as the uh the american cup logo
and the year and we look forward to
bringing this event back uh next year
and in many more years to come irina
congratulations thank you tony and thank
you to everyone at the chess club uh
thank you to rex and jeannie for
sponsoring this event again and i'm so
happy to see the uh the club bringing
more top tournaments and expanding uh
now to the whole block of america's
avenue um you know thank you to the
commentators to alejandro
you guys were great and i enjoyed
watching you in my free time
well thank you very much guys thank you
tony for everything you do for the st
louis chess club organizing these
amazing events and what a beautiful
tradition starts off today
thanks becky well congratulations